nurse presentation of her dissertation
proposal
she will be presenting her topic
evaluating intestinal microbiral
Dynamics across perturbations to predict
treatment response and chronic
inflammation Christina has a background
in molecular biology and microbial
ecology
she views the human as a as a ecosystem
and her main interest is to understand
the relationship between microbes and
hosts Christina hopes to get back to
doing some wet bench work once she
completes her PhD
she has two dogs that keep her company
while she works from home and they've
been exploring various parks and trails
in the Vancouver area
I just want to give a little
um
I'm an outline of what's going to happen
today Christina's going to present then
there'll be opportunity for all of you
to ask questions
and when questions complete
um those of us who are not on the
committee will step off of the WebEx and
Christina will stay with her committee
for any final discussion
and with that I turn over the
presentation to Christina okay thanks
Karen and I made sure to feed the dogs
an early dinner so they don't harass me
while I'm trying to get this
um and I see that it's recording
okay so as Karen said my topic is on uh
looking at intestinal microbiome changes
or Dynamics across perturbations to
predict treatment response in chronic
inflammatory conditions and to best
answer this I plan to take a salutogenic
view or approach
and this model of Health views Health as
this process along a Continuum rather
than the more traditional pathogenesis
view which really looks at Health by
trying to understand one disease one
treatment approach
and cytogenesis also views the human as
a system with interconnected subsystems
and one of these subsystems is the
microbiome
it should change there we go okay so
down here you can see one of the
subsystems the microbiome and the other
subsystems are depicted along this Outer
Circle
and these can be
affected over time by factors such as
stress your genetics and your lifestyle
and these factors
can lead to an Health outcome that
affects like your blood pressure or your
temperature or glucose levels
okay
um sorry
box
um and in regard to the health of our
gut microbiome we know a lot about the
mechanism behind chronic inflammation
and its association with an imbalanced
or dysbiotic gut microbiome
so certain conditions chronic
inflammatory conditions such as cancer
Alzheimer's disease inflammatory bowel
disease and obesity are known to be
associated with this imbalanced
microbiome
and that can be depicted in this right
image shows kind of a lack of diversity
so there's not as many different colors
as this healthy gut and what happens in
this dysbiotic gut microbiome uh
condition is that the intestinal lining
barrier loses integrity and the toxins
and byproducts that are supposed to stay
in the luminal space can cross that
barrier and enter your bloodstream and
this can cause endotoxemia and constant
endotoxemia leads to chronic
inflammation
and I do want to Define uh what I mean
by gut microbiome I'm just saying gut
microviolin GM but I'm referring to the
intestinal microbiome which is are the
microbes including like bacteria viruses
fungi and archaea that live in uh are
intestine and on our intestinal wall
so given this link between gut
microbiome dysbiosis chronic
inflammation and the pathogenesis of
chronic inflammation
um I I'll look at chronic inflammation
as kind of the disease model
to understand this overarching question
is of how does the Dynamics or changes
of the gut microbiome impact host health
and this really looks at gut microbiome
Health along a trajectory a chronic
inflammatory conditions uh you can see
here
um
these outer boxes represent different
conditions that are associated with a
dysbiotic intestinal microbiome the
ultimate or long-term goal of this is to
prevent or reverse the pathogenesis
using the information from the gut
microbiome in a more closer goal would
be to
um identify indicators of risk for
dysbiosis so more about early detection
and prevention of dysbiosis and this
will allow us to give us potential for
improving or developing our microbiota
medicine so like a probiotic
interventions or diet or even like fecal
microbiome transplant
and one chronic inflammatory condition
that is well studied and known to be
closely associated with gut microbiome
dysbiosis is ulcerative colitis which is
a subtype of inflammatory bowel disease
and it's a complex complex chronic
inflammatory condition described by an
inflamed colon
in this diagram I was from Clemente and
all that did a systematic review looking
at different studies that tested
perturbations or treatment interventions
on mice and human models of colitis the
perturbations they looked at include
diet
probiotics antibiotics and fecal
microbiome transplant
and they found that there's a shared
Trend with increased
bacteria or decreased bacteria
associated with ulcerative colitis
versus a healthy control and so blue is
more abundant red is decreased abundance
they also found that microbial
byproducts such as short chain fatty
acids are decreased in colitis
conditions and then other immune markers
are also affected
um a approach that I propose to take
that's a little novel is to apply this
concept of resilience to understand this
re relationship between gut microbiome
Dynamics and chronic inflammation and
this concept of resilience can be
explained with this ball and Basin
diagram
you can see one state here State a which
is represented as like a non-inflamed
gut a balanced gut a happy human and
then this day is an inflamed gut with a
dysbiotic or imbalanced microbiome and
the system which is the ball what can
happen is the resilience is low and the
perturbation is strong as frequent
enough the perturbation can push the
system across its threshold or Tipping
Point and cause a critical transition
from State a into State B
so that's kind of the the concept of
resilience
um
and the width and Basin of this diagram
represents how resilient the system is
so the state a is less resilient State B
is more resilient because of that depth
um and how narrow it is
so one of the challenges of this concept
is that this
uh
term resilience is complex and it's
multifaceted it's also a very context
dependent term so for instance this
concept that resents has been applied to
many other
disciplines so such as like brain health
or even like soil systems or lakes lake
systems and over the next few slides I'm
going to discuss more about how I'm
going to break this term down so that I
can actually apply it and understand how
it relates to the gut microbiome the
human gut microbiome
so to apply the microbiome features to
resilience I'm going to first talk about
what I mean by microbiome features
species diversity is the number of
different species in an ecosystem and
the relative abundance of each species
and you can kind of
see that from these pie charts over here
the different colors represent the
number of different species and the
abundance
and then taxonomy or composition refers
to the bacteria relative abundance
functional potential or relative
abundance refers to the bacteriology
family relative abundance so in other
words taxonomy is the type of bacteria
function or functional potential is the
um what the microbes are doing
potentially and I've selected these
features because diversity has been
found to be associated with um
healthy posts so a greater diversity
more healthy foods and then with taxon
function
kind of like the previous ulcerative
colitis diagram I showed there are
particular talks and functions that are
associated with increased inflammation
or decreased inflammation
and then applying these features to
resilience similar to the bond Basin
diagram I just showed we have a
community of bacteria here like a sample
in state one and then the idea is this
does this shift in response to
perturbation to a second state
um
and the idea is that um when the
community shifts from State one to state
two does the diversity taxonomy or
functional potential change and if it
does how much does it change what are
the features that explain that change
so one of the challenges as I mentioned
with resilience about it's a complex
term and there's also no unified or
validated definition to kind of measure
uh resilience for the human gut
microbiome
so for my project I propose to focus on
just one component of resilience
to get one step closer to being able to
characterize government resilience and
post health
and so the component I plan to look at
is recovery
and the definition of resilience that
I've adopted from Shuffle at all is the
system's capacity to bounce back to
normal healthy Baseline functioning
after a perturbation and the two key
components of this resilience definition
is the resistance which is
the degree of change the system is after
perturbation and then recovery which is
um
the system's return to Baseline after
the division so I plan to look at
recovery
and then these two diagrams kind of um
depict the recovery in a high resilient
system and the low resilient system
the idea here is that the faster the
recovery
um
a faster recovery is more indicative of
a system with greater resilience and
that's shown with a deeper Basin has a
steeper slope so the system kind of
rolls or returns to that equilibrium
faster so it has a higher recovery rate
versus a low resilient system has that
more shallow
Basin so the this
slope is less D so it has a slower
recovery rate or lower recovery rate
and I do want to point out a key
consideration here
um is the rate
I will be able to look at microbiome
features that are indicative of recovery
but not necessarily informative of the
rate I will be able to interpret
how time Point distributions affect
microbiome feature cell
please
so the ultimate goal is to understand
the utility or use of the gut microbiome
Dynamics across these perturbations to
assess post-health and treatment
response and chronic inflammation
and I propose to do this with the
following aims so the first one is to
evaluate perturbation dynamics of the
gut microbiome in healthy longitudinal
non-perturbed and perturbed data sets
and this allows to determine if these
Dynamics are informative of Health
second I will build a predictive model
to predict treatment outcomes in
different chronic inflammatory
conditions based on pre-perturbation or
Baseline microbiome features this will
help us understand the features that are
more informative of gut microbiome
response to perturbation
and I hypothesize that there will be a
subset of features that are indicative
of post perturbation gut microbiome
changes and also that are predictive of
host treatment response in the multiple
chronic inflammatory conditions
so to start I'll talk about aim one
evaluating the use of perturbation
Dynamics and the main question here is
are the longitudinal Dynamics
informative for assessing the ability to
return to a Baseline
and this question was inspired by the
study by Olson at all that looked at
temporal changes in bacterial abundance
in healthy adults
um
they found that the intra-individual
variation does stratify
in healthy adults and this is a just a
graphical representation summarizing
their main finding
um
they were able to categorize the
temporal Trends they saw in these
non-percivation healthy individuals
and found that there are species that
categorize into stable bimodal and
variable species so when the question
comes up it was like if we see these in
non-perturbation 10 Pro trains how do
these Trends look in a perturbation gut
microbiome response in healthy
okay
so for the approach I'll be using
independent publicly available data sets
of longitudinal and particular time
series of healthy human fecal
metagenomic data and this will be to
identify significantly different taxa
and functions and measure the variance
between time points across each time
series and so then I can compare them
across these cohorts of normal and
perturbed uh healthy adults
trying to show a
conceptual representation of this
um here's a normal gut microbiome time
series and at each time point I'll have
either the taxonomic relative abundance
distribution or the functional relative
abundance distribution
and then here's a nice lightning bolt
with the perturbation so this shows the
perturbation Time series
and the microbiome features I'd be
measuring is the alpha diversity which
is the variation within samples the
taxonomic and functional relative
abundance
same
thank you
in the between the time points to
identify which samples are significantly
different in community composition and
function I'll be doing a longitudinal
differential analysis
differential abundance analysis between
the time points and that will also allow
me to identify any key texts or
functions that explain the difference
between each time point and then I can
compare those between normal and
perturbed
to measure the variance between time
points and get the Delta I'll use the
bray Curtis dissimilarity metric
which is a commonly used measure to
assess how different microbial
communities are
a little more details about the data
sets I'll be using
I'll be using
the healthy individuals from that Olson
paper the that found the trends in the
temporal
and
um
this non-perturbed time Series has four
time points per individual across a year
the second cohort is of a perturbation
data set of antibiotics
um and there's 10 individuals as control
who are not given antibiotics
um this was 23 time points across four
months the third cohort is also
um an antibiotic intervention in healthy
individuals only advisor five
individuals
this one had uh 11 time points across
about a year
um and then to show details of the time
series
the non-perturbed time series the time
points were collected equally across the
year
across four visits
the second cohort
the samples were collected during
Baseline during the antibiotic treatment
period uh weak follow-up and then for
six points
for the remaining weeks of follow-up
so six sample points per follow
and then for the third cohort there is
one time point from before the
antibiotic treatment for during which is
the orange and then six points follow-up
and you can see each individual kind of
has some variation in the time between
the time points
between cohort 2 and 3 the antibiotics
used was different so that's
um
something to consider
and then this aim will inform us of the
potential utility of the post
perturbation gut microbiome as an
indicator for host health
and also help us understand if these
temporal Dynamics compared to the
perturbation gut microdynamics are
informative
of a healthy cohorts
and then for my second aim I'll be
creating a predictive model to predict
treatment outcomes and
multi-chronic inflammatory conditions
and the question here is can we utilize
the Corsa of Baseline microbiome
features to predict treatment response
in different chronic inflammatory
conditions so different conditions
um
or diseases that are promoted by chronic
inflammation such as like cancer
autoimmune disease and metabolic
syndrome will be looked at
and this question is really getting uh
whether gut microbiome features that are
predictive of treatment response if
they're shared across different chronic
conditions chronic inflammatory
conditions
and I'll use
um
publicly available independent data sets
of perturbation perturbation data
um
and
I will be using the pre-perdivision time
Point microbiome features as input and
the outcome would be a binary treatment
response
and I plan to use a random Forest
because of the variable importance
aspect and also random Forest is good at
handling high dimension data which is
microbiome data
and variable importance will be measured
by how much removing a variable
decreases the accuracy
there we go
so the disease perturbation data sets
I'll be using are of again human fecal
metagenomic data
and the conditions I'll be looking at
include recurrent cluster drds difficile
infection with a antibiotic followed by
a fecal microbiome transplant
intervention
uh the other conditions include active
ulcerative colitis severe Crohn's
disease obesity non-small cell lung
cancer and renal cell carcinoma and then
active ulcerative colitis again
and the other interventions include
people microbiome transplant surgical
resection a weight loss diet
intervention and then for the cancer
cohorts in anti-pd1 followed by
antibiotics or not and then FLD
and as far as the responses the outcome
response defined in these data sets they
all Define the outcome in a binary
manner but they use different disease
metrics because they're all different
conditions so to simplify the treatment
outcome for my purposes I'm going to
categorize these into
success or failure treatment so a
positive or negative response so for
instance the C diff infection response
they Define it as a cure or recurrence
this one was clinical remission or no
response so for these situations cure
and clinical remission will be
considered a positive or successful
response versus recurrence or no
response as a negative or
failure of treatment
and then for building the model
I'll take these
independent data sets of the conditions
I'll split them 70 30 and the 70
training
sample will be combined and then I will
train the model and also do the leave
one out plus validation for tuning the
hyper parameters
the
random Forest classifier would then be
evaluated with the 30 holdout set
from the combined data
and I'll evaluate the classifier using
the measure of a uroc the area under
receiver operator curve
the model will then also be validated
using the separate
ulcerative colitis with equal microbiome
transcend perturbation data
and the predictors I'll be using for
this will be coming from that
pre-precurbation timeline so the first
time point
and the microbiomeasures will be Alpha
diversity taxonomic and functional
relative abundance and then also I'll be
including clinical and demographic
measures including sex HDMI and if
possible I'm going to see if I can
categorize the disease severity and
development severe
but I'm not quite sure if that's
feasible yet
and then the outcome variables
um you know how like I mentioned it will
be binary response or no response
um
so this aim2 will allow us to identify
the
Baseline microbiome features that are
predictive of treatment response across
these conditions and to assess how
general or specific these features are
how shared they are across the
conditions
um and then I'm going to go through my
workflow so I have a lot of different
data sets that I'll be
um
acquiring from different databases
and I'll be doing pre-processing them
all the same
so I'll start with the raw metagenomic
short reads I'll do quality control and
filtering I'll normalize the reads and
then I'll also transform menu data I
also forgot to include in this diagram
that
um
assessing the batch effect is really
important for microbiome time series
data so I'll be doing that
the output from this will be the
filtered sequencing reads which I'll
then assemble into longer sequences or
context which I can then annotate the
taxonomy and function so identify or
measure the taxonomic and functional
relative abundance also can calculate
the Shannon's diversity or Alpha
diversity index
there's also
two other indices that's been developed
that if I have time I'm planning on
assessing the gut microbiome Health
index and dysbiosis score
and these will be my microbiome features
and then I'll use that to input into my
A1 perturbation Dynamics analysis step
to do that differential analysis between
time points to identify taxa and
functions and then I'll measure the
delts out between the time points and
compare those between Time series
so the output from aim1 Will
either be that the perturbation Dynamics
identify key taxon functions that are
more indicative of a perturbation rather
than
temporal changes so if that's the case
then I will use that information to kind
of supplement my model
so that my model is based on tax on
functions that are more informative of a
perturbation rather than just normal
temporal Dynamics
for the predictive modeling as I said
I'll do a 70 30 split and train and test
the model evaluate and then validate
with the Unseen ulcerative colitis fmt
data
and then this will give me the future
variable importance and the model
accuracy metrics
and even if uh if aim1 output shows that
the temporal Dynamics and perturbation
Dynamic Dynamics are not distinct then I
can still have information from aim1 and
in the random force model will be built
from the microbiome features
so since my study uses secondary
analyzes some current challenges with
that is that I do have small sample
sizes
which may lead to sampling and power
issues there's also a potential bias
from using these different data sets
that could come from different
collection methods
the data sets that I'm using were also
collected for a different purpose than
what I'm doing so that's also a
consideration
hover the key goal is to provide a
framework that can be utilized with
other microbiome data sets and is
agnostic of disease or tissue so that
our impact is not limited to analysis of
this data alone
so in conclusion microbiome features
that are predictive response to
perturbation could be informative of
treatment response in these different
conditions
such as like probiotics or prebiotics
antibiotics fmt and also understanding
the gut month around perturbation
Dynamics and assessing these common
predictors can provide a foundation for
future work to improve treatment
efficacy and success in patients with
chronic inflammation and overall the
goal is to understand gut microbiome
Dynamics and um
oh as a trajectory
and I'll say thank you to my committee
uh committee members Shannon mcvinia
Alicia Michael Mooney and Sean Gibbons
also thanks to the faculty and staff of
demise and my fellow students and
friends and to the 215 Grant
thank you for that presentation let's
now open it up for questions
I think I definitely talked a lot faster
than I thought I would so yeah a lot of
time
I have a question
um I'm less familiar with the data sets
that you're referring to
um and I guess my my question is do you
have any do the data sets contain
information about whether the patients
were being treated or changed their diet
or did something different that might
have an impact on the the gut microbiome
um some of them do and some of them
don't which made it kind of tricky
um let me go back to the data science
so it's good that you have some that
have those data because it seems like
um
ultimately we would want to know how to
coach
patients and and for clinicians to
provide guidance on what to do when
somebody has one of these conditions
yeah it is interesting some data sets
have like a very extensive like uh
daily diet diary
and others don't so the
to be able to kind of integrate these
data sets and use them together
I'm just using microbiome features and
pre and post application
thank you
again if you have questions feel free to
raise your hand or put a question in
chat
hi Christina this is what's your name
can you hear me yep
you're quiet Nate can you speak up yeah
sure
um so I'm curious on Slide 26.
uh
do you plan to use all the data sets to
train the same model or different models
uh train the same models
okay they're trying to say model yeah so
I'll be training one model with 70 from
each of the data sets
okay
I have an another question one of the
tables you showed showed um whether
somebody was active or in remission so
I'm assuming you have some kind of a lab
test or something that tells you when
somebody is in clinical remission like a
cow protectant or something
that would tell you whether someone's in
remission or whether they're still
actively inflamed are you talking about
this one
yeah so each uh study uh defines that
outcome different but for instance like
with those sort of colitis and Crohn's
disease they usually do like a um
colonoscopy right or use like a male
Spore so they all use a different Health
metric
um but the study already defines like
this Patient responded or this patient
did not respond
so that means there'll be some
variability across your data sets as to
what a responses so you'll have to to
account for that in some way I guess
yeah yeah
I think that's one of the perks of the
random forces the interpretability so
hopefully I can see understand what's
going on
well thank you for listening everything
I have Christine I actually have another
commenting question so if you're using
all of these data sets in the same model
um how are we going to control that the
different
um
that essentially these different
conditions have may have very different
unperturbed
settings and the model can use that to
predict
um the outcomes
specifically for some of these data sets
where there's a high class of balance
like that first
get that first one
does that question make sense
yeah you're asking like
um
with the variability and conditions like
what if the microbiome features are
really different
yeah yeah in each experiment that the
unpreturbed microbiome conditions could
be different
and so it seems like it could be hard
to delineate response versus
non-response versus
you know just predicting based on the
experiment itself
for the data set itself
um
so the goal is to understand
not necessarily
what Futures are most predictive
uh in the different conditions but what
features are shared across them so if we
find that there there aren't that many
features that are shared across the
conditions and that also tells us
something
um
[Music]
okay myself thank you
okay I'm just gonna give give one more
shout out anybody if you have questions
um feel free to speak up
um otherwise we're going to close up the
session from the public and and let
Christine and her committee meet so
let's give another minute or two to see
if anybody else wants to ask a question
very impressive presentation thank you
we have a question in the chat
can you see it Christina says how much
concerned are you about sample size and
power of the study
[Music]
um
just for Manish yeah
it is a very like preliminary
assessment of these microbiome features
associated with like recovery and
resilience
um
so I mean it's a concern but I'm still
going to do this study
um but there are ways to evaluate the
random forest model and also with the
aim one the time series and the
perturbation the idea is that
um
I'm comparing the Deltas and differences
between time points
so that I don't need to worry too much
about the sample size
well because Tina I have a question here
so seems like you have a different type
of diseases right see you have six
disease do you expect the same set of
features can be applied for different
vertices Beyond random forced based
classifiers
um yes because they're all known to be
associated with the microbiome changes
and also
uh maybe I'm not understanding your
question correctly but they're all the
same data type so I will be able to
calculate those measures from them I
think he's going at your actual
hypothesis Christina which is you know
do you really believe that there will be
commonality across all these diseases
right which is exactly what you're
trying to assess
yeah I think there will be because
there's a lot of taxes and functions
that are associated with like
um
either promoting or inhibiting
inhibiting inflammation that we know
about
um
so I think we will see those kind of
trends across these different
inflammatory conditions
so for instance like that short chain
fatty acid
microbial byproducts that they know is
decreased in ulcerative colitis
um
that
this guy
that's usually decreased in inflammatory
conditions and then other functional
Pathways such as like um
uh LPS
lipopolysaccharide I'm blanking on the
name but LPS is usually associated with
greater inflammation so I think there
will be taxon function that kind of
distinguish
um
that are identified
should you actually try to evaluate to
evaluate like C
using a seposite of disease i3cs learn
the features same may be Shield across
subset of diseases or something like
that
so more kind of um selecting diseases
that are more similar to each other yeah
or just to try to try to validate your
your hypothesis Shield or these features
the class of different diseases is
easiest right
yeah and the idea with uh
validating with this separate ulcerative
colitis fmt datasets to kind of try to
understand how generalizable those
features are but it is a small data set
um so I could find other
conditions to look at
okay but in casely your random Forest
classified performance is not good so
you may have some alternative approach
you see I should really focus the subset
of disease instead of trying to
averaging everything up right you will
lose a lot of sleep on beach yeah and I
think uh for alternative approaches the
random Force really doesn't work well I
could try a simple linear model or like
a other models such as like support
Vector must genes and kind of compare
how those do
okay
see now I'm not seeing any other
questions posted or any other hands
raised we want to thank you for the
presentation and now I would ask that
everyone including myself
will be stepping off and Christina and
her committee will will stay for any
additional discussion well done
thank you